father you gotta give us a freestyle
[Music]
[Music]
everybody I'm Evan Britton welcome to
another episode of hot boxing with Mike
Tyson this is my man Mike Tyson hey
what's going on everybody we have an
awesome get here today
awesome man here today even though other
than the one the only logic guys that's
pretty epic I enjoy
hell yeah Bobby Tarantino yeah in the
house they just put that on a mixtape
make that a mixtape intro the young
Sinatra straight up oh yeah that's been
just massive success 100% think about
going [ __ ] people up and getting on
right here exactly it's doing this keep
making this money looking good I agree
doing this just mind your own business
they focus they posit hands on nobody
yeah it's awesome
totally great great wisdom right there
you've got a very powerful message
you're a young dude how long you been
doing what you're doing
um man just like anything like you know
all creatives artists athletes I think
you kind of start doing it since you're
young so since I was a kid I've been
rapping having fun doing my thing it's
awesome milk gathers burger that's close
to where I live at like seven locks
crazy yeah I didn't do time in seven
locks but I've been to seven locks a lot
you dive into a lot of psychological
stuff ego stuff consciousness talk and
the last line of the song confessions of
a dangerous mind your latest single yeah
as a
put your ego on the self and on the
shelf and remember to love yourself
that's powerful man that's what we're
all about here you know I don't know if
you've do you watch this show I've seen
all the clips on Instagram so really
yeah I went through them is they're
really fun you ever hear about the toad
the toad MTD now dmt I mean you mean
like the drug yeah medicine parent oh
yeah yeah yeah you take you smoke it
it's from a frog venom you smoke that's
not scary to me that for give me a panic
attack just talk something is
frightening once you take you but once
you go through the process it's free its
transformative that's like my buddy I
think it was Frankie was like hey man
you want to try this this new strain I
was like what's it called he's like
insane no thanks for the strawberry
pop-tart yeah it's good blueberry muffin
yeah yeah that's a good one yeah what
what made you become a rapper rapper um
tell me why rapper did you look at
yourself from a different from everybody
else perspective my rap is different
this is but this is something I can do
for me it was something that really it
allowed me to just express myself cuz I
never felt like I had a voice you know
what I mean I never felt like just
growing up you know broke and welfare
and you know the same old story I just I
don't know man it allowed me to just
kind of paint another picture another
world it was really cool you know it's
so weird you think of what that stuff we
were all on welfare broke too but I
never thought about wrapping or anything
you know so yeah talking my mind I talk
to myself in my head dog [ __ ] what do
something we can [ __ ] money without
going to [ __ ] jail well you can and
then you found boxing it's interesting
how you find your path yeah it's just
the universe yeah exactly it's truly any
what you're called to know what what
you're called oh yeah what you're called
to a hundred percent will cost to you
right so
yeah but also for me it's like I'm
excited now to get into film I have a
novel that I wrote called supermarket
that actually comes out this Tuesday and
it's a work of fiction COFA both good
oh man it's um it's basically about this
guy who's writing a book for the first
time and it's hard because I've been
trying to describe like figure out the
best way to describe it in interviews
and stuff and it's like a it's like a
dark humor kind of psychological
thriller meets Fight Club like nice
pretty wild yeah does it take place in
the supermarket it does which is
inspired by like cuz I fight I worked in
the supermarket you know what I mean
when I was a kid like one of the jobs I
hated I worked in this bakery for this
lady who was like so mean she was like a
James Bond villain
so where did getting us did you hang
with yeah gotta go with the with the
desk yeah yeah it's so weird with my
kids honey I kids there to take pictures
of the boudoir kids go in that's real AM
Potomac yes the weird thing I always I
always tell people about Marilyn is like
you could be in like the nicest
beautiful neighborhood and take a left
and then it slowly marathon yeah it's
crazy
yeah but though the most influential
black and the come in the country live
demand Potomac yeah shout out push T
yeah well put season Bethesda's I put
that I still know the most predominant
the best schools one went to the best
schools makes the best money they all
live in Potomac why do you think that is
I have no idea yeah that is we know I
think was it close to DC yes the suburbs
I think I'm partly for massive slavery
black people prominent early the early
prominent black people were from DC mmm
you know their jobs and cars madam CJ
Walker knows because that was the
mason-dixon yeah which was the
separation of the south and the north
yes right that's interesting
first of all can we just talk about how
I've never been to a show or things just
goes like the subject matter is so epic
like one minute we're talking about
rafts and then the next talking about
slavery that's crazy
yeah the location
this is what it was all about like this
yeah there we go
bro that was so different we are people
I don't care what reason we're all a
part of our past whatever it is yeah I
mean related you know one day Ben
Affleck he wanted what's Ben Affleck it
was Ben Affleck that was embarrassed
that he had slavemasters and his family
not putting on anything I remember and
you can't you can't help we rock check
who we are now no that's real and me
yeah yeah that's how it was for me kind
of like breaking the cycle you know like
growing up poor and around you know
drugs and all that lets out like I
didn't smoke weed for the first time - I
was like 27 really like I hate it when I
was in high school but you're trying to
smoke like you're Snoop Dogg and impress
your friends and it's like this whole
other thing and back in Maryland it was
how illegal it was it was like this
whole thing but nowadays like yeah I
mean I just started kind of smoking oil
a little bit to help with anxiety very
big it really did yeah that's how I I
have eight brothers and sisters Wow
[ __ ] I know so I'm the only
child between my mom yeah so it's weird
so it's weird cuz I was like raised at
parts of my life with like all these
family members and then other parts it
was like just me in a single mom anybody
with me though yeah Jeanie I mean a
couple of them for sure and at different
points in times but Jeanie my sister
she's super sweet and Jesse's what are
the ages you're 28
yeah I'm 1229 20 so late 30s in early
30s pretty much and then oh but I'm the
baby so ever okay yeah cool so you guys
are all in the same like you don't have
a brothers wait actually how could I
forget
Ashton so my dad 64 years old had a
vasectomy after I was born
yeah actually I don't know how I feel
about that my dad has a just had a baby
oh I hope they're happy just now yeah
you know he just gonna work oh babe
he said he got a DNA chess and it was
99.9 and everything that was like yo I
thought you were shooting go slows man
your brother looks strong
that's strong yeah well talk a little
bit about you know growing up to come
and now you know you've had some great
success man and and I mean you're doing
well for yourself so talk a little bit
about that transition what that's been
like for you yeah it's weird because for
me there was never like a day and night
it wasn't like oh I was super broke and
then one day I was just like mega rich
like it didn't happen like that and I
even say like there's only two crazy
things that I've ever bought with my
money and one of them is this Rolex and
I got this because I was nominated for
Song of the Year at the Grammys and I
was like man what's wrong and I had been
able to afford it for some time but I've
just always been like I don't know kind
of just fiscally responsible because
it's not just me it's also you know like
the people I employ they're also my
friends my family you know because you
got to trust the people that you're
around and so I always felt instead of
buying crazy cars or XYZ to make sure I
can build a company build a brand but
yeah I mean welfare sucks
I remember like powdered milk and you
know waking up smacking a roach off your
face which is disgusting sucks you know
but I think it humbles you and when I
started rapping
and wanting to get into music I never
saw it as like oh yeah I'm just keep
[ __ ] and hos and money in this it's
like not I saw it as a business like as
to be a business man to say you know I
want to be able to create quality music
in the studio from my heart and then I
want to go hustle and sell that [ __ ]
like a business man with you know I mean
yeah I want to there's a clip of you we
found how it's a great clip dude it's a
[ __ ] it's legendary right here
and it's you talk doing some interview
and you're basically telling this guy
like I don't [ __ ] do that [ __ ] yeah I
love that part I don't [ __ ] with no one
yeah
I was 24 it's my first festival ever Wow
no no because I don't [ __ ] with nobody
nobody so it's very simple I stay at my
house and just me my homies my fiance my
little puppy I just got and I don't [ __ ]
with nobody I don't go anywhere I don't
go to parties I barely go outside
like literally I really don't go outside
that much I know that seems a little
weird but I just I want I refuse to
allow any sort of cancer in my life to
spread so I just stayed that's positive
as well do you ever watch this clip
social looking beef shirts tardy
expression media was everything for me
to attain my feet my fan base dude I was
like a hundred and thirty pounds here
I'm 175 now thanks to Pepe Pepe is my
trainer Joyce really what do you guys do
we do a lot what we're doing right now
is more so like just like fun intense
training cardio mix our weights mixed
with like you know all that but there
was a time it was like last year
actually like it was a month ago last
year I just decided like I really wanted
to finally get in shape and finally get
healthy so like because I used to smoke
cigarettes bro
like I used to drink nothing but
coca-cola like I got a pee right now
because I drink so much water you know
like now it's good yeah like honestly it
is flush room yeah you got to go you got
to do it keep moving it come back do you
have to go now in fact okay I mean if it
gets bad there may be a fire dude you
had a lot of fire there you know I don't
[ __ ] with nobody yeah you know you know
and you've seen a lot yeah definitely
and in this music but do you think this
[ __ ] is your friend he's not
your friend after [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] me over
who's nobody you can trust that and it's
a scary thing it's guys did Adam we came
in this [ __ ] together and he [ __ ] me
over and then the music better tonight
then let me know you fighting your best
friend
she's an animal
I mean that thing shoot at each other
did you know Mike had a record label
really back in the day smile he's like
dude what was it called tell Tyson
record it was really crazy back in the
day what would I do it's about fifty
million dollars and that [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
my god money back I don't understand the
fact I had fun
it does sound good did you take care of
your artist though too much they got -
yes you were - nice - yeah that's the
but you're very empathetic you're good
dude that's why yeah you just want to
help the world but then you learn I've
been there you know there's a difference
between like yeah I mean talk about that
yeah just in general like I've had you
know friends artists that you really
want to help but then you actually find
out you're kind of just enabling them if
you do certain things for them like they
need to learn to fall down I fell down
there was nobody there for me
and so I think that's the thing is that
guy could look at these you know even
just friends people whatever like man I
just want to be there for them because
nobody was there for me a lot of thing
that thing I think um oh I don't know
you thinking gravity I think I think the
industry turns these people into like
savages and mean cutthroat people cuz I
don't think they come to the movie
industry having no idea these people
gonna be like this yeah but see and then
I also think that a lot of those people
themselves get corrupt because it's like
oh [ __ ] this person [ __ ] me over to
get ahead well I gotta [ __ ] the next
person over to get ahead or XYZ and it
go primitive thinking yeah and the fact
that I remember baby in those guys I'm a
little winning I'm winning and talking
abouth showing the fifteenth and an
eighth to open I like to open up for my
fight for me am I really and really yeah
that's right and now you see these guys
fighting over money yeah she'd left body
fighting over money why over money cuz
they got no other outside influences or
something you should be able to be the
fly thing in the world ever
this and then to have all the money
let's keep it to yourself
they're not they're not very given in
that industry yeah music I mean hip-hop
in general it's it's a it's a wild place
man
that's why for me like my message was
always like peace love positivity treat
others well like take care of yourself
save your money
you should saw this when I first started
in the 80th minute was crazy this is
crazy this was crazy listen right now
you see the young brother like yourself
as well talking young man come and talk
like we were saying anything about a
rapidly same thing about rap music and
it was bad
somebody would come up to one of those
that were confident and he would start
beating on us and we're on the air oh
we're in a time when they're wearing our
cars driving we got in the door and I my
guys that's a trip I mean begin to park
you know it's weird especially social
media social media makes everything
crazy like just like could listen and
this rapping we have the images stuff
yeah and I can't learn nobody to destroy
that image outside right because if your
image is you're a gangster you have to
factor it show that I love the peace
love and positivity message yeah I mean
but I get [ __ ] for it like course you do
ya have the heart the heart guys gotta
give them [ __ ] you know actually are
dudes that actually understand they've
been through it and they're almost like
yeah not straight up like like be
yourself like you ain't got to try to
pretend to be nobody it's the fake him
[ __ ] who oh yes I who are full
of hey
we are given a cipher he'd like the
intelligent rap ruling a little ad with
that long back in the day and age they
had an intelligent rapper true not one
guy yeah one getting totally rap name
that's I'm with that that's how I wanna
be remembered you know having a message
but also it's all it is fun to turn up
though sometimes just make some flinch
it oh definitely
yeah that have fun in life dude Oh can't
we just you just got a vibe thanks like
listen this is like Zen man yeah I don't
talk to a monk then man just like go
with you man it's all gay I'm on that
path yes I feel like you like you'd be
cooking accidentally chop your pinky off
and be like this is just fine you're fun
no man I mean that's well that's what
I'm all about but my comments how was
Egypt brother happy it's a trip listen
man there's no particular driving laws
there that's right here am riding back
on our own car and so we're just driving
people walking and you gotta get to
commit to when you close do you have to
commit it there's no lights in the car
they keep coming so when you get open
your sky committing don't hesitate yeah
and that's what it's about
people are like bumping all no I'm sure
no one has parents dear that's insanity
that's sex it's just really it's just
poverty this is America the best oh no
this is the best place in the world I'm
gonna country the Middle East in the big
shot
yeah oh man I do I love it
that's great there's a lot of wild [ __ ]
going on and it's a government and XYZ
and all that but I tell you I do love
where I live it's only places so my
violet you dissin you can go to the Long
Point Center that's them right there
you some countries you somebody violet
you or hurt you you point them out to
the cop the cops gonna take you right to
them let you let him do anyone see you
ain't funny
Hannah how do did you get to walk around
at all oh yeah so what you went to the
pyramids
yeah I did that to knows the pyramid the
pyramid was just found mind-boggling I
felt like was that Holly something was
just a spiritual awakening Wow and I am
absolutely totally yeah these people
built this [ __ ] they took 30 years of
people to build this so I mean you're
starting your grandkid to finish it you
know Wow yeah thirty years I want to go
there really bad just to see the
pyramids I definitely want to go there I
want I want to go to Africa as well and
then but my kind of freaked out a little
bit about it well I talked to this you
look up the crime in South Africa the
high traffic Lee the trip damn yeah
you're talking about left the
nicest-looking part of Africa South
Africa and you'll get robbed yeah it's
wild
I was Nick where's Nick on duty had a
great time we had the hash there was no
weed in town food man I'm just like so
how was it
just wait beautiful being on a hash tag
with the once you give it a shot and you
get off good noon we came to Germany
with start smoking some weed and man
totally different does it [ __ ] you up
not talking with them has you that pull
just in the zone yeah that's why I'm
chilling I just like we man yeah that's
sweet dude there's this guy I know who
takes people to the pyramids he's been
going there since he was 15 and he does
ceremonies in the tombs where they're
doing chanting you lay down in the
sarcophagus well I never tried down with
him me neither I would do it I would do
it call me nuts so listen we saw a lot
of these guys were imprinted all their
family members it was phoning each other
you can see had all of them had
Walkingstick yet affected them right
yeah all her hips problem cuz they all
had walking sticks because I wanted to
keep the pure blood right through the
lineage so they were all like kind of
doing it with each others currently
today we do yeah I mean it's like 2,000
years ago
or longer than with the Pharaohs yes
yeah well you know it would fit the
rough childhood practice some kind of
rituals like that as well I never heard
that
please don't kill me that's like the
richest family watch out yes they're
descended from Pharaohs did you know
that Rockefeller into them I'm telling
the truth
yes yes you're telling the truth listen
tap that some distance what is defendant
that someone is the truth shall be towed
you know they've been conquered by Greek
and all that stuff and then Noah thumb
and the bread but half that for money
yeah yeah and the lineage to be able to
find all the way back to like the
ancestors there's some [ __ ] [ __ ] up
heavy [ __ ] going on dude with the uber
wealthy people oh no that's just giving
me anxiety just thinking about it hey
Mel that's real you know all we can do
is just the bringers of light dude I
guess you know what I'm saying no I'm
with it yeah you do
can i really actually take that break to
go pee my mama Sherman and Peabody yeah
yeah Sherman and he looks like the kid
from Sandlot growing robbers showing us
videos from your shoot to career filming
it was dope as hell gonna punch it I'm
really yeah and a good time it was look
great looked awesome dude this is a fun
kid right hit yeah he is a good kid Mike
do you see that you know you won that
High Times cup award best new brand bro
yeah brother there you go big you ought
to try this Veit Mike this is some
Alaskan Thunder [ __ ]
like you know I want to go to Egypt man
oh man so did you get to walk around
like the bazaar or anything like that
yeah what in the medina Zenith all the
history of touch and all that stuff man
was it crazy beautiful
are people just coming up to you
constantly but I didn't pay attention
you still in - it's awesome
The Mummy yeah the mummies are cool
what's your sign man I'm gonna query us
you know you love me laid that guy yeah
yeah it should do more chill now that
I've smoked weed this water Sun actually
the emotion will do air sensor which is
crazy but because it's the guy like
pouring out the water or something I
know yeah but yeah I'm an air sign Libra
Oh sick yeah brother
what about you might cancel water so you
said that it was a gradual sort of
ascension for you yeah like for me
getting drafted into the NFL
I went from broke college kid to
millionaire me two in one check that's
what happened to me I went for my
[ __ ] gutter kid to [ __ ] like
upper-middle family white [ __ ] family
I'm [ __ ] he's letting everybody know
he's very he's an alpha white male he's
letting anybody know this is this this
point the part of my family now you
treated with respect to treat us and my
[ __ ] head is so big and it's [ __ ]
way to me wow that's what he's going for
it
I can't even imagine though like that
like that is so but I that's why
sometimes I feel pretty grateful that it
happened the way that I did with me you
know that I'd it was just like millions
that [ __ ] me up though yeah me too
yeah absolutely
[ __ ] my relationship with people not
knowing that this was about a year
aboard and I couldn't think I didn't
want to take that responsibility like my
limits and now you're the boss
I'm the boss I was there I'm no I
wouldn't dare say you don't go through
it may give you an order you know yeah
and I'm the boss and that [ __ ] me up
that's a hard thing to have that role
like myself just being this kid
everybody tells you what to do your
parents tell you what to do there you
come from you'd be making are you the
book now swamp now what do you want us
to do son
yeah damn yeah that's a trip yeah Mike
you can [ __ ] smoke like smokes this
is no [ __ ] joke in here y'all
yes he does I'm definitely catching guys
that guy up this year right now oh yeah
brother
goddamn the Union Father friends yeah
mom
no unfortunately yeah yeah both my
parents were drug addicts alcoholics but
with my dad you know even though he's
done he had done some messed-up stuff in
the past man we really you know we
squashed it like he's my dad
you know you only get you only get one
and the same with my mom it was just a
bummer cause it was like harder to talk
to her cause she was just like very she
was like not really mentally well yeah
you know for me my father was cool cuz
my dad was expecting kind of afraid of
my dad too but that would look [ __ ]
Church coming over looking with friends
bought me this put me to car him like
you have a brother
yeah you ever you talked to him a few
months periodically often he the doctor
where's he live he lived um what's the
name in this town again
Soweto Cerritos Cerritos California yeah
oh cool oh that's cool little known fact
about my sis this is such a fun values
hey Mel we have fun here
you know preesh so you really came to
weed late yes early you ever tried any
psychedelics no no
I think my mind is too active for that
[ __ ] yeah yeah like I would overthink it
you know I mean it'll be just what it is
you need to take a trip right now I
packed my bags I haven't unpacked my
bags then this [ __ ] earlier I don't know
man you know man these things are
different because they interact with
your brain in a different way
what psychedelics yeah you know they
show you things about your life things
that you've probably thought about that
you know will be confirmed
you know truths about yourself that's
what people like buddies of mine who
have you know done like LSD or even
shrooms and stuff like that I've said
even though the experience might have
been crazy or really good for half of it
and then really weird for the other half
that it really opened up a lot about
themselves and showed them a lot yeah
which is dope yeah then you know so
that's kind of where we're at you know
these days because cannabis is being
legalized and then these psychedelics
are starting to be realized as medicine
yeah you know to each their own
of course that's the real thing that's
why for me like I think smoking weed was
such a difficult thing when I was
younger because it's like oh don't be a
[ __ ] like you - that's the realest [ __ ]
but when I get older right yeah now you
don't I do it I don't want to do it so
for me I'm all about like micro dosing
like I just have a hit screw and I'm so
I'm sure that's all I need like what Who
am I trying to impress I'm a grown man
like I just want to relax and eat some
Cheetos and watch this Tarantino movie
yeah for sure yeah this Tarantino your
favorite director yeah for sure he's
dopest [ __ ] man I love you I'm actually
working on two films right now that I
wrote and I'm starring in don't man yeah
which I'm really excited about one of
them's wait were you the kid insanely I
wasn't the kid I used to clear that up
you snapped right now Internet's my to
be going on
ya know but I'm working on my first film
is produced by JJ Abrams track baby is
it so far as we know no no it's not it's
just a comedy cuz he's greasing it
through bad robot so he's not drunk yeah
but it's fun man it's like it's like a
newer version of clerks ok Oh kind of
like clerks like [ __ ] super bad
what's your favorite movie that's a hard
one dude I can name no I mean I got
Fight Club interstellar Pulp Fiction
Kill Bill kill bills the reason I got a
hip-hop wow really yeah [ __ ] old
masters the kung-fu masters involved
with yo that shit's wild that [ __ ] in
the matrix oh my god 20 years ago this
year yeah well we talked to this guy
again who invented some artificial
intelligence [ __ ] and I'm convinced
we're headed to the matrix I think I
mean we're gonna be in those pods to
just getting my juice with VR beeping
machines like asleep having a few life
nobody can do you put you all your
qualities and stuff against another
rappers quality and the Terr who's the
best rapper really in a computer yeah
that's wild using AI you take like
millions of points of data from your
whole career your whole who you are put
it into a computer computer would spit
out like a virtual image but you can do
the same with like fighters Yeah right
yeah we talked about that that's pretty
well yeah yeah it's a trip dude I don't
know that I want to be made up in a
computer I don't [ __ ] all that man but
maybe we already are as I know bro I
just saw this Orville episode you guys
never watched the Orville it's almost
like Star Trek so with four violent yet
but it's like realistic and funny that's
sweet
anyway they just they just did an
episode where like they find a I phone
from 2015 and then upload it in the
simulator and it creates this person
it's so wild yeah okay I'm gonna go back
to Tarantino
you know about his new movie once upon a
time in Hollywood hundred percent can't
wait first time Brad Pitt and Leo
Leonardo DiCaprio in a movie I'm pretty
stoked about it's about the Manson
murders
oh yeah Sharon Tate cool
do you remember anything that era that
was before you know I think for my time
yeah I was [ __ ] we as old man yeah
yeah where it was a daycare [ __ ] the
other kids at yeah Mike what's your
favorite movie [ __ ] think about it yeah
I like um what was that movie with um
the butler one of those deeds no the
butler that's my [ __ ]
the Butler's one of Lee Daniels with
Butler yeah like that one like Forest
Whitaker yeah like you like dramas
notebook
oh no books glass breaking down walls
Time Traveler's Wife no I haven't time
travellers wife dog or [ __ ] with this
guy's wife and Olli what did she find
those you are for a moment either happy
to get away from me who are you I never
thought I'd be talking about romantic
movies with Mike Tyson yeah nobody
thought that is really yes it is I like
fun movies though
yeah like comedies animation Big
Lebowski oh come on dude the dude last
they did the best
it's one of my gurus you know you are
the dude that's what they say that's
what they say I did Mike you got any
other trips chips coming up mm-hmm
listen I don't know this [ __ ] work that
he's gonna call people from that's how I
feel see me and I'm in [ __ ] Egypt I
don't know I wanted to go too easy to
see the parents I said this is [ __ ]
legit Pam to go
look I know who's gonna call me tomorrow
listen listen I don't know this because
when for these calls I'll be a broke
[ __ ] I don't know what
I'm all over the work and I stopped by a
big house it's all good how did [ __ ]
work about you I broke my [ __ ] you give
me what the it comes again like you're
like the happiest guy in the world
oh listen man I did this [ __ ] I'm at the
beginning I did this [ __ ] wrong man I
fell in love with myself and cacao my
you're taking life as it comes man
laughs a lot enjoy life sit man have a -
brother where's where's your favorite
place you've traveled Hawaii Maui oh you
come outside your room it's beautiful
oceans right there a little bit of sand
in the ocean it's dope as [ __ ]
running the Maui in the shape anywhere
anywhere
intense like Egypt no not really
how'd I do I want to go yeah I wanna
like you've done you've toured and yeah
definitely
but not like not a global tour no I've
gone out of country for sure but more so
like Europe yeah listen you go some of
these countries have to be on TV it's
good to look at people think what da
[ __ ] do they make human beings look like
this yes you [ __ ] out when you see how
beautiful certain people look in other
parts of the world what the [ __ ] is
going on
you might see somebody I'm really dark
like with blonde hair and blue eyes I
see why they solder not like that yeah I
mean they don't that native people do
you think that like some alien races
came down and mingled with I don't know
that's my wife fizzles but I believe in
aliens bro my wife believes my wife
believes in the film once you believe in
the matrix you believe she had the
booklet children of the matrix you
believe that stuff bro it's a fun thing
to dive into your last album or is your
new album with wu-tang last album had
wu-tang
is crazy love would say you know OPPD
900 dB wu-tang clan is like why I
started rapping I just I hit the RZA hit
RZA and I was just like yo like what do
i do man to get you guys on a track and
he was like all you got to do is ask yo
he's yellow and but they're all just so
cool and it's just nothing but respect
it's pretty amazing
that's dope as hell do ya dope as hell
it's pretty dumb so he brought what as
you said to man turn to you know so he
brought easy Gewehr what I'm aiming
Cavell come on can tell the girl Iggy
Azalea Thank You Z Leo the black girl oh
is Lu bang a very bangs very banks to
this Rob Rob Tarantino flick right she
started fighting where I think the
Tarantino guy really really yeah
multiple [ __ ] Remy Ma do you favor
Remy
yeah Scott Jackson yeah Mike let me ask
you something what's one of your
favorite memories in general good
question
well I don't know having some I remember
things I remember I'm Miley getting
beaten by Larry Holmes
yeah and 1980 it was October 2nd 1980
remember that we there know that I was a
closed-circuit watching it Wow know I
cried a lot damn messed up what about
you don't know ma'am do you have a
favorite one of your favorite memories
I've had some big ones man the day my
daughter was born Wow huge one I just
remember thinking you know it was one of
the most profound things I've ever been
witness to is a life coming into the
world and like
you gonna be [ __ ] up I was gonna be
like the first time I play playstation
Nam's kid yeah
what's yours man one that comes to mind
is uh you guys know red rocks in
Colorado it's like a it's like a
beautiful amphitheater yeah it's like
10,000 people you should check it out
it's like the potato is carved in the
stones of the boulders it's insane and I
went there in 2013 with Kid Cudi and I
opened for him dick Jolin and then I
went back a few years later and sold it
out myself and headlined and I brought
my buddy Lembo who's like my best friend
out excuse me
and it was like we had a real moment
like I cried on stage I was like there's
10,000 people here like I dreamed I
could have sold this out and they give
you an award that's like made out of
rock and it says sold out and it's a
piece of the Red Rock that's sir it's
really beautiful so this one for me as
an amazing young guy starting doing this
box and stuff I want all the guys the
greats to know my name yeah you know I
mean I wanted Frank Sinatra no me the
biggest thing with Frank Sinatra those
guys knew me like I was just Mike like
Mike to them it wasn't like yeah I was
gonna say Mike come here Mike I need
right here now somebody call me if Mumia
[ __ ] this is cool and it's cool with
people you like really love and look up
to you ya know who you are there's been
some surreal moments where that's
happened and it's just like man that's
it's so cool too it's just like about
acceptance it makes you feel accepted
it's dope it's good vibe I don't know
about your time I met all those guys for
my mother's like Bob Hope all those guys
I met all those guys limber all those
guys met all those kind that was just a
really big moment for me you have any
Sammy Davis Davis working with those
guys those guys what's on your bucket
list one of the things you want to do
mine was jump out of a plane and then I
did it how you come out Everest really
yeah
summit that [ __ ] that's crazy
yeah well right now my bucket let's be
gonna go to the seven wonders where he
went
five wooden got two or three lefties
like a pocket we saw so we gotta do
something else
know what about space would you go to
space of Elon Musk and get you in outer
space I mean no I'm not gonna be the
first flight though say you guys have
fun dude I'll be here with my shoes on
the [ __ ] earth
and that's [ __ ] blowing up no
thanks I wonder mmm we plan to take
Martha Pluto you see birds fly right
what do you mean do they have
well there's technically no life on
other planets that we've discovered as
of yet no I think it's bogus I don't
think they tell us everything you think
we don't know he'll leave right no there
are as many galaxies like ours as there
are grains of sand on a beach yeah
that's what I'm saying there's
definitely something else out there like
what the [ __ ] is that mind boggler it's
just bizarro versions of us multiverse
is this other other dimension that's how
you know we're high when the word
dimension you guys ever get these Ovoo
yeah this is a really interesting thing
to me when you are in a situation or
having a moment where you're like I've
been here before
isn't that extreme but I always wonder
if it's also like maybe you were in
similar situations like in the past like
putting on a watch a certain way maybe
heard a bird and it just hit something
something it's some shift of
consciousness I was discussing with
somebody um they had the intestines I'm
hearing a mummy and they found the mummy
had cocaine at the back on his hair now
that's just the archaeologists probably
just drop their drugs so they this day
they're probably figuring that a
particular time it was the ancient
flower here that emulated cocaine and I
feel at one particular time we like to
tobacco must have been here at one
particular time but it doesn't it's not
here no more but it had the been hand
for the foot being so I said to myself
some ignorant high on cocaine gets out
of my system and really a moment in turn
just five thousand years right well in
the [ __ ] here
so it stays in here all stuff we do no
matter what technology that they can
live I know that I had no idea and no
idea for yet if you can look at the
cocaine mummy the cocaine mummy coke
money Bobby you got to give us a
freestyle [ __ ] no Mike Mike were you out
would you I would I rat before when
Chris Mara supposed to fight soldier boy
I was supposed to Train Chris Brown and
we were getting ready to fight and
listen listen um Evan this is what
really freaked me out this one I know
this is serious it's just that we're
doing this a podcaster because I'm these
crazy one foot and the Bible's gonna pay
to watch these guys fight it was 16 and
they wanted to see it they want to see
soldier boy fight Chris Brown yes what
houses the people with him it was about
to happen
yeah happen I'm Chris Brown didn't wanna
do he got I think got a little gum
bubble guts like he actually [ __ ] his
pants sir Oh scared Chris Brown yeah he
didn't want to do it but these guys
wanted to give him with Timmy now
whoever he wanted whatever yeah that is
kind of crazy we're at a point where
like people would pay a lot of money to
see to celebrities or no people know if
the violence the nature of violence he
has wild what is that we love it they
have the blood loss no but it's like
it's weird
everybody football boxing UFC oh let's
listen all those things that we didn't
have for sports with forms of war yeah
yeah we read head and plane kicking it
head around what if soccer you see the
Impaler China boom
you cut off the enemy's head you start
kicking it around and you try to fight
with your other team that's how
in fact well no thanks the football
football is just two armies colliding
yeah that's pretty dope no Bonjour
gather the gladiating if my little one
into winners you're a football fan uh no
I'm not really a big sports guy
no nah man I loved skateboarding growing
up so I was like stuff like that yeah
now either yeah skateboard accord Jesus
nah I believe it bro wait Jesus like a
wild laugh Mike when you were in Egypt I
was in New Mexico yeah weather what's
skiing what yes
how what was it like I won selling
almost killed myself would you go again
I don't know I bad memory I wouldn't
listen I'm ski I'm coming I'm snow clown
right and I don't know this though but
you know just skin as soon as you hit
the soon as you hit the ground concrete
no you coming right about the skis you
flying now sure I didn't know that I
will aim to do boom it's so funny cuz
like I don't smoke when I do interviews
but like you guys definitely got me just
secondhand [ __ ] I know but for me it's a
like argue I just yeah I just I'd love
to get my work done
yeah that's just the type of person I
don't get my work done make sure yeah
I'm just super on point and then at the
end of the night watch some anime
perfect smoke a giant watch Reservoir
Dogs yeah the poverty does that to you
gotta be on top of the game [ __ ] yeah
yeah you've seen for me at one time had
a lot of [ __ ] Nate lost it I never want
to be a dealer on top of this [ __ ] I've
noticed a thug tell you yeah
and lost it all I've been there [ __ ]
yeah that's a dark place just trying to
have fun man that's my biggest thing is
enjoying it you know enjoying the ride
sure you're married now single single
yeah that was yeah that was a long time
man sometimes things just don't work out
yeah it's all good yeah not just for me
you know just making sure you're happy
everybody's got to be happy yeah
semester well it also taking takes a lot
of work to continue to be happy yeah I
mean a lot of people don't want to work
on themselves exact that's that's what I
feels like even like with anxiety or
certain things it's a lot of things that
you might not be dealing with internally
yes yeah I'm really big on that that's
why I like if I get anxious I don't
smoke weed yeah like I deal with my inks
I get through it yeah yeah that's good
no no I mean it takes [ __ ] you have
to get up every day and make a choice
about what your mindsets gonna be yeah
you know I think too many people walk
around feeling entitled to joy or
happiness now you got to work for it you
have to work for ya internally if to
cultivate that you know and that's
awesome and that you know you're doing
your thing thank you you're finding
success and I wish you nothing but it
thanks dude no I really what are you
looking for the what at the end of the
game everything I'm doing right now but
with a family yeah you know some little
kids like I wake up every day and
whether I want to make some beats or
write some raps or produced for other
artists or write a book or write a movie
like I'm so blessed I mean you're
blessed man you wake up you could do
whatever you want
it's incredible and and I'd for me it's
not even a stress but the only thing is
too like maintain that just to work
smart so that I can continue to wake up
every single day doing what I love yeah
to teach in the game yeah I've got some
some artists that I work with for sure
one that comes to mind is John Lyndall
he's an incredible singer he's amazing
and it's just fun to like because he's
this young guy
it's amazing to kind of see where it's
almost like dealing with yourself and
you're younger so you just want to give
him the right advice and all that but
he's like a singers like a pop singer
you [ __ ] insane he's really good work
with Justin Bieber nah I never work I
mean I would just because he sings
incredibly is yeah I mean yeah it
doesn't discriminate it's too good it's
dope - so what's your main focus right
now in music or you kind of letting
yourself do musics always ooh yeah
musics always like the main thing that I
do cuz I just love it so much
but I guess diving into film is the new
goal and I'm excited for that so that's
the goal I'm going after it's awesome
heroes oh man that's a la me RZA off
jump Tarantino as I said yeah Lenny he's
my best friend and he's one of my heroes
man he was there for me when I really
needed somebody but those two like when
it comes to music and film there it is
and the probably Ernest Cline who wrote
ready player one that Spielberg
different yeah yeah for sure I mean [ __ ]
that's another story and that's about to
unfold that would you see that no one
just like we were talking about earlier
like living in this synthetic well it's
insane VR is crazy have you guys ever
been an avoid well I've heard about it's
like a huge VR yeah yeah yeah so you put
the whole thing on in the walkthrough
yeah it's crazy yeah but this place is
like a hundred thousand square foot yeah
thing might get a VR game Hitler day
yeah well this guy got hip to us his
name Ross Albrecht
yeah he's the Silk Road the dark dark
dark web Silk Road
yes Duke well yeah
tell me about him he's a pretty awesome
water you know I don't know about him
yeah he did some stuff that was pretty
amazing you know but I don't know I
don't know his psyche I don't know how
he thinks I don't know I feel like the
German mind thinks but what he did with
the duck was pretty interesting yeah
what's the name his alter ego named the
captain Pirate Roberts pirate captain
Roberts or someone yeah and he went to
jail for really long life like man took
a triple life Hey Joe Joe thanks I left
my water it's my [ __ ] I'm gonna eat I'm
[ __ ] starving I think I'm gonna do is
drink or worth or break dude is
legendary no we always think of a like
funny strain names yeah give us some
maybe you could come to Tyson ranch and
you can name some strange purple
dinosaur not be noble with the name the
purple dinosaur alien anus strawberry
pop-tart I'm just giving all my [ __ ]
away or every pop-tart yes it's a good
one it's pretty good all right these are
pretty good ones
hey William Amos I just thought what
that was hilarious
there it is brother let's [ __ ] wrap
this thing up thank you guys you got
anything you want to show me I didn't
know anything I just wanted to know that
I had a blast here today and I got a
book coming out called supermarket which
is droppin on the 26th so get it enjoy
it and peace love and positivity as
always awesome brother
thank you guys tell me you got any cuz
of that real Street talking [ __ ] I get
the fight like urethane earlier Oh
hundred percent my brother's [ __ ] they
was the ones who was like hit that [ __ ]
and I was like 12 and I was a man to
drink some milk take shower shut the
[ __ ] up
well I had fun man thank you really
thank you guys thank you great up Mike
we're outta here guys like chocolate
please subscribe on iTunes Spotify
stitcher tune in iTunes all that [ __ ]
YouTube
[Music]